la première comparution du français
zacarias moussaoui devant un tribunal
américain c'est aussi la première
procédure judiciaire qui fait suite aux
attentats du 11 septembre une procédure
de pure forme mais qui a permis de se
rendre compte de l'état d'esprit de
l'accusé etienne leenhardt aaron dimon
sur place c'était donc pour acariâtre
moussaoui le premier vrai rendez-vous
avec la justice américaine
arrivé sous bonne escorte eu très tôt ce
matin le jeune français de 33 ans
apparaît pour la première fois devant
ses juges un uniforme vert de
prisonniers une barbe fournie pas de
menottes aux poignets
moussaoui est calme il écoute sans
interprète plaide-t-il coupable ou non
coupable à la présidente qui lui pose la
question moussaoui debout répond en
anglais au nom d'allah je n'ai rien a
plaidé je ne plais de rien comprenez
dire à son avocat américain qu'il plaide
non coupable
une demi-heure plus tard moussaoui
quitte la salle d'audience sans un
regard pour le public il n'y aurait de
toute façon pas vu sa mère restée à son
hôtel
aïcha el wafi n'a pas voulu risquer en
se rendant à l'audience de le
déstabiliser
ici il me voit moi je sais pas bien et
lui apparemment elle va être la même
chose et moi je préfère qu'ils soient
sereins qu'ils répondent à ces questions
qui vont reposer et des questions la
justice américaine en a à revendre
arrêté par hasard pour une histoire de
visa au mois d'août dernier ici dans le
minnesota où il prenait des cours de
pilotage
moussaoui est tout simplement accusé
d'être le 20e pirate de l'air le seul
qui n'ait pu embarquer à bord des avions
détournés si la cour à partir du 14
octobre prochain arrive à prouver qu'il
était directement impliqué dans les
attentats
moussaoui risque la peine de mort et en
faisant juger zacarias moussaoui ici
dans l'état de virginie le gouvernement
américain prend en quelque sorte des
précautions supplémentaires en effet
avec le texas la virginie et l'état
américain dont les jurys populaires
condamne le plus facilement à la peine
capitale
la date